all saddened to hear the news of
jeopardy game show legend alex trebek's
passing yesterday at the age of 80 after
a battle with pancreatic cancer
we had the honor to sit down with trebek
twice last year once talking about
the meteoric rise of jeopardy james
it was exciting in our studio it was
exciting nationally
and i suppose it might have been
exciting in vegas as well
we were also allowed time for a quite
reflective interview from september 2019
when alex talked about his fight with
cancer
his deep appreciation for the outpouring
of support and how a home improvement
project fixing a maine water lake
took on a higher meaning for his wife
jean and alex trebek
i told my wife i said i felt really good
about
being able to do this sure because i've
been feeling
very very weak i have trouble going
upstairs
and it just it was so satisfying
and to be able to do work like that
around the house if you care for your
home
and you take pride in your home and
you are one of those individuals who
when something goes wrong
wants to fix it immediately then these
are the kinds of things that bring
tremendous satisfaction
and i love it i wondered if alex was
aware of how the way he handled his
diagnosis
with such optimism and bravery even
vulnerability
inspired others in their own cancer
fight i don't feel that
i'm a great inspiration in that way in
terms of being a tough guy because
there's nothing i'm doing to overcome
serious problems
your reaction to it has inspired them
so it's really it's well whether or not
you know you're doing it you really are
and that's that's a good thing and i
thank you for viewing me
in that way we thank you alex for being
a talented and gracious legend a warm
and welcoming and scholarly part of our
day for nearly four decades
and so very brave in the face of
adversity eight news now extends our
deepest sympathies to the entire
jeopardy team
and i know ted standing by with weather
and i believe denise
ted also got the chance to meet alex